all right joining us now here it is we
have Herschel Walker 50.1 and uh Rafael
Warnock of 49.9 uh we've got 72 percent
of the vote in Mr Speaker this is your
home state of Georgia uh pretty close
race how do you analyze it up to now
well I think up to now and I think Bill
Hammer has been really remarkable in his
coverage
um what I read is that Herschel is doing
as well or better than he needs almost
everywhere
that in fact probably by the time this
gets done tonight if if it's accurate
that they counted the early voting first
then the rest of the evening we'll see
Herschel gradually pull further away now
again you've got some huge counties out
you had Fulton Gwinnett Cobb DeKalb
these are huge counties and so you can't
fully be sure what will happen but I
would say as of right now that looks
better for Herschel than I would have
expected I mean I'm delighted with where
we are right this minute and uh I think
all of us should just you know hold on
tight and let's see what happens the
rest of the evening but it's certainly a
sign that all the lies and all the
smears and everything that was done
against Herschel didn't work it's also a
sign to be fair that Governor Brian Camp
who is clearly the most popular and most
powerful politician in Georgia has had a
huge impact in the race and he and
Herschel together are the two Heroes of
this evening if they end up winning
because without his deep strong support
you wouldn't have had the turnout that
you're getting in rural counties you
know I asked this question of Senator
Johnson I'll ask you the same question
Mr Speaker if I had the perfect voting
system that I believe would have the
most Integrity for the country and that
everybody would have confidence in the
results in I would make Election Day a
national holiday I would go to paper
ballots uh I would make exceptions for
the military the sick the infirmed
people that might be away on business
they can apply for an absentee ballot
short of that I would have partisan
observers from every party watching the
voting in every Precinct and then
watching the voting vote counting after
the uh after the polls close start to
finish up close we get the results at
the end of the night but until then
don't Republicans have to work the
system that they have and the reason I
say that is because it seems that the
Democrats they're more in the ballot
business than they are in the business
of selling ideas or campaigning you know
you we barely saw Katie Hobb she
wouldn't debate Kerry Lake fetterman
didn't debate Dr Oz until 700 000 votes
were in and one week before the election
uh I think Republicans have been
unwilling for whatever reason reluctant
resistant to voting early and voting by
mail do they have to get over that
reluctance that resistance
sure look I mean you you have to play
the game by the rules that are existing
uh that means from for example if you
want Generation Z voters you've got to
be on Tick Tock even if in fact in the
long run we may abolish Tick-Tock as a
Chinese Communist device it means that
you have to recognize early voting it
doesn't do Republicans any good to save
their TV money till October if they've
had a third of the vote come in in
September so and if people are going to
have early voting the huge advantage of
early voting is unless you know who to
focus on because they haven't voted yet
and let me just point out Democrats
focus on elections Republicans focus on
campaigns Democratic Consultants
ultimately are paid to win elections
Republican Consultants are paid to buy
tv ads for campaigns very different
models and as I've indicated in the
newsletter that's going out tomorrow we
need to really rethink from the ground
up not just at the surface but from the
the ground up how far Republican
Doctrine is out of touch with reality I
want to ask you one other thing and it
got a lot of notice when you said that
you believe Republicans are
underestimating Joe Biden that even
surprised me
well look I I got to it in part by
watching the Bulldogs work their way to
number one and thinking about football
and frankly watching my beloved Packers
not work their way to number one and I
realize that you know there's a Clarity
in sports there are winners and losers
well the truth is if you back out by his
standards to achieve what he wants to
achieve Joe Biden has been pretty darn
effective and he had just had one of the
best off-year elections in American
history if it wasn't for Kevin
McCarthy's leadership on the house side
the Republicans would have had a bad bad
night and so I would say to you we have
to start by being honest and respectful
of our opponent and our opponent in this
case turned out to be a heck of a lot
more successful than we thought he would
be
Pelosi ran a dictatorship with great
power in the house you can despise it or
dislike it but it achieved what she
wanted it to and what Biden wanted it to
so I think you've got to start with the
reality and that that's I have a new
newsletter coming out about rethinking
from the ground up we need to understand
the Republicans live in a fantasy land
and do not confront the reality of what
they're up against
stay with us Mr Speaker we're going to
go back to you throughout the hour we
appreciate your time hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else